so welcome everyone to
the data science hangout and welcome
back to
those of you that have joined before and
i think most of you have joined here
before
but welcome also to first timers as well
so this will be a discussion on
data science leadership in the
enterprise and
ranging from very human oriented topics
to a little bit of technical talk as
well
so just trying to hit that sweet spot
and focusing on questions that are most
important to you all as well
so as in prior weeks
please feel free to speak up and ask
questions or
use the chat window as well but with
that being said i'd
love to introduce elaine mcvay vp of
data science at the luma project
elaine would you be able to uh help kick
things off here by sharing a bit about
the work that you do on your team
sure yeah so the the limit project is a
small early stage startup and
i've been going to smaller companies
each time i
switch jobs for quite a while now and so
this is the
the smallest place that i've been um
although
we're growing quickly and so we
do uh storytelling via film in
grocery stores and so we have tablets
with like 30 seconds
of human centric
films essentially so this is our take on
more
human oriented storytelling oriented
replacement of traditional advertising
and so there's some
interesting things about
looking at how to understand what
components of film
drive uh connections with consumers
so we have some film analysis things
that we look at
and then also looking at you know time
series of sales and understanding
and the impact kind of causal impact of
things that we're doing so a lot of
different interesting
angles and going along with being a
small company it's a small
team so there's three people on the data
science team currently
um and so yeah so a lot of my
experience has been working with
companies that are rapidly changing
in smaller environments with smaller
teams which is a different set
of challenges and opportunities than
having a really big established team at
a larger company so
i think that's something that probably
resonates with a lot of people listening
in now
and i i know people will start asking
questions as we go so i just kind of
want to kick
some kick it off with a few questions i
have
but one thing we've been asking everyone
every week is what are you really
excited about
with data science right now
yeah i think the one thing that's been
on my mind a lot
then and i don't know that this is
quite in the core of data science but i
think comes up frequently in my
experience
at work and also is kind of driven by
what's going on in the world
but i've been thinking a lot about how
we communicate and package
data science work
to stakeholders or the public or whoever
whoever it's relevant to in a way that
kind of
balances the analytical integrity that
we're responsible for
with some level of pragmatism
about how humans actually make decisions
for better or worse
and so i think that can take a lot of
different
um paths but it's it's partly about
like really understanding where data
science fits which i think
varies a lot from organization to
organization and
and we can kind of influence a huge
range of things but
generally aren't doing all of that in
any given context
and then figuring out like what is the
appropriate level of rigor
for what you're doing and the way that
the results will be used
and how do you connect that to
the decisions that will be made and have
and and
like what the human factors are in
making those decisions
so some of the things that i've been
thinking about in that regard is
whether data scientists
can get farther into the process
of really taking detailed results
and getting to the what's often like
kind of the packaged
end result which is painfully simpler
often for people who understand all the
caveats of what goes into it
but if by doing that we can be better
representatives of
kind of the integrity of the process and
also have more impact
by moving farther up the
communication chain as it were
is that something that your team's
starting to do
yeah we've thought a lot about how that
plays out in different contexts so for
some things that are
operational decisions then
kind of a higher level of detail and
getting people to understand more detail
can be important
whereas things that are more
marketing or sales specific we need to
understand in detail but then also
need to really be able to communicate in
very
simple high-level ways and i think it
takes
it takes a lot of concerted effort for
people who are trained to do analysis
and think about
uncertainty in very precise ways and all
the different
you know outcomes and ways to interpret
things
and a lot of caveats and set that aside
and think about what are the big picture
takeaways that will matter to the
audience
who's receiving this and how do i
simplify
all the complexity without losing the
core
of what's actually going on
um and so i think we also like just
observing the world
trying to deal with uncertainty through
the pandemic and all that you know
watching science play out in real time
in a way that is difficult for people
who aren't
scientists to handle with things
changing and
a lot of uncertainty has has really made
me think about how that applies also in
a
business context and whether there's a
you know whether it's better to provide
results and let someone else decide how
to present them to the audience
or whether it really makes sense for us
to level up
our ability to do that to be more
involved in
in where things end up
i think about that a lot when i see
things on twitter
as well if i like look at a
visualization real quick and try and
figure out like
what did i learn from that or was i able
to even answer
a question there yeah and i think it
often takes
a lot more effort than we want it to
to get something to the point where
someone can
get the right takeaway really quickly
um in a way that's still connected to
the data and so
part of what i've the shift that i've
been making and encouraging my team to
make is that
that effort is worth putting in in most
cases
and that we shouldn't think of it as
like our job is to get the right numbers
and then all the polish and
communication and everything that's kind
of like
not the right emphasis because we're
focused on the analysis
and really to think like we are also the
best people
or at least valuable people in doing
that
translation and even if that takes just
as much time
as the analysis you can almost not
invest
too much in that in terms of the impact
that
that you have i see
a question that came in from ian and he
said he has a lot of background noise or
else he would ask
live but his question was you mentioned
using time series to analyze
or derive a causal link to your
advertising
what kinds of models do you use for this
high level
is this like multivariate um i'm
not going to read all the model types
but i'll let you weigh in there
yeah we're just getting into the best
ways to do this and i think
there will be a few different models
that were
that we're landing on for different
purposes and so there's
the need to both be able to forecast
and to be able to understand what's
happened
and it's i think we'll have different
models for those
two purposes so we've just gone through
a process of evaluating multiple
modeling approaches and trying to
determine the right one
and then are now identifying data that
we
really wish we had to add in and that'll
probably be another
iteration as usual in terms of
evaluating the the modeling approach
but some of the models that we have are
considering time series
specifically and some are not and so it
kind of depends
on what the outcome is
thank you and again it's a then the
challenge is like how do you communicate
that to the stakeholders
of what's going on how much do they need
to know about the models and the
differences and
and what are the takeaways
christian just um asked a question as
well in the chat
christian if if you feel comfortable and
want to jump in and maybe just introduce
yourself
and feel free to ask that as well
sure can you all hear me yeah sounds
good
hi so i'm christian i'm waving but my
camera's not on
so um but i'm waving um
i'm the data science manager here at
cosmic
pet um we are basically a pet hard goods
um wholesaler but of course we work
fairly closely with a lot of our retail
partners
um one of the so one of the things that
i'm really responsible for here
is like forecasting making sure we have
enough inventory
and obviously over the last 18 months
that's been um an exceedingly difficult
challenge with how
covid is really affecting
like everything and now even um i mean
obviously when it was here like sales
were crazy
for some things and really really crazy
for others
but even now that things are starting to
level out it's like
a lot of our models we're seeing like
for the last
year like everything every all the
patterns that were normally there in our
data are just
different are you guys seeing that are
you
running into that how are you kind of
working with that
yeah i am by no means an expert on
time series or forecasting but my
initial thought in looking at data a few
months into covid is just
like every model everywhere
is now going to be broken for a long
time
because there's just so many impacts on
so many things
and this kind of time so we definitely
saw
um you know there were major impacts on
grocery purchasing that kind of spiked
and then it gradually
leveled off and and declined somewhat
but are still
above previous levels and then also
a lot of changes in how people purchase
things
and you know also like people looking at
how much of that you know curbside
pickup and online ordering
is going to stay versus people reverting
back to going in store so certainly has
accelerated a lot of
behavioral changes um in terms of data
this is one of the reasons that
some of our modeling approaches aren't
time series based and are stead
instead comparing things in different
ways so we have some
things that we can compare to like other
things in our
in the categories that we're in so
categories are
you know like wine um dairy things like
that and grocery for people who don't
live in this world
and so we're able to look at the overall
trends
and compare the impact of what we're
doing to
those in a way that isn't explicitly
dependent
on modeling history
but even before the pandemic it was hard
to forecast
for a lot of specific products what to
expect because of
a lot of new products and and seasonal
changes that affect them differently and
just a lot going on so it's a
challenging problem to begin with and
then covet changed
everything so um yeah
it will get easier now that we're
getting into
some historical data that's been all in
the covid period but obviously there are
still effects and i
imagine there's no perfect solution
except to think about various
ways to um we're we have the advantage
of
being able to compare things in a way
that if you're trying to forecast a very
specific thing
then you've got a harder problem
and just that looking through the chat
looks like matthias you maybe had
something
to add on to that as well
yeah no i was just completely agreeing
with
elaine what you just said um we were
trying to build a marketing mix model
here internally for one of our brands
and uh we absolutely did have that
problem of
now all of a sudden we have uh covet
affected data in our test set
so it's hard to actually verify how good
a model is now
because all of those time series are
just messed up
yeah i think it's a good opportunity to
be creative and
thinking about other ways to tackle the
task at hand
but if you have a very specific forecast
to me that
painful situation i don't know if anyone
else who has more expertise in this area
has
good suggestions
romney it looks like you're adding
something there in the chat as well
yes client could do the magic like if
you
like for example like the unemployment
it went up really fast
if you add spline and then make
assumption about the decay
you know this is the point that you
don't know where it's going to land off
so you can do
different decay rates and suggest
like what if we're going to the fast
recovery slow recovery and then use it
to future
similar event like like if you know
first wave
we had the first first wave and then
like we're going to have like a second
wave how it's going to look like
so i found it as something really useful
yes yeah um prepare for a range of
possibilities instead of trying to
really pinpoint
what to expect as a better approach
yeah i played around briefly just trying
to add like some
indicator variables for like different
phases of cobit
and trying to get that in there but our
in a lot of cases our data isn't
necessarily dense enough
anyway so it's like just trying to
parse that out between what's actually
coveted and what's true seasonality can
also just be a challenge
yeah yeah and i imagine there's a lot of
interactions that are hard to predict
also like for pets i know
tons of people got new pets during the
pandemic
and so we just correct we're kind of the
overall
level of demand the things that people
need
might be different if there's you know
more new pet owners and
more puppies yeah and people are really
more
engaged with their pets too so we saw
things just like
um like collars or leashes or harder
goods that like
dogs like pets won't chew up will spike
like had like one spike and then they
more or less kind of like came down to
normal maybe it's partly because of new
pets but then other things that like
toys that they would like
destroy would have like more and it's
more of a sustained increase there's
there's all kinds of stuff in there yeah
so that's all fascinating unless your
job is to predict what's about to happen
it's so fascinating it's just i'm
balding at a much faster rate than i was
uh pre-coded
elena i see that eric asked a question
um
around one of your previous points eric
do you want to
weigh in and ask that live yeah sure um
can you all hear me
yeah all right cool um so elaine it's
great to have you talk to us again i
know we've had some great conversations
of past
our studio conferences but um i know for
every organization can treat this kind
of differently but
i don't know if you had any tips on you
know maybe setting up
data scientists to be more involved in
key decisions that are made
like an organization level um at least
in my industry that's
becoming more and more common now um
especially with the
type of data we deal with but i don't
know if you have general tips for those
that
kind of want to have a seat at the table
so to speak on those
and those key decisions yeah i think
you know some of that is like
organizational
where data science sits in the
organization and and how high level
representation you have but in terms of
what's
easier to control for most data
scientists i think it is
the best approach is to learn a lot
about the business
and understand how to communicate with
your audience and do more of the
translation of not
like this is what i this is what i did
to get to this result and these are all
the things you need to understand about
it from a
data perspective but to say like
this is what this means for you and you
know like the more we can
present things in a way that fits with
how people are ready to receive things i
think that's
part of building that credibility and
and people feeling like the data
scientist isn't this
you know brilliant magical expert who
sits in the corner
and and then other people have to take
what they do and figure out
what to change but that we're like
constructive parts of the business and
decision making conversation
and we can kind of keep all the critical
details about
what we have to do to get there out of
the way
except when we're talking to our teams
about the work
but that's hard you know even if it's
something that you can do well
it's hard to do in any given situation
where you just come out of
you know putting all this work into a
project and like extract
the details out of your head when you're
talking about it
i see that don asked a question and was
wondering don if you could provide
some context or background with regards
to some of the work that you do
um yes yes sure can you hear me okay
yeah uh hi yeah my name is don bunk i'm
a data scientist at exo basis digital
which is a digital analytics company in
burlington vermont um i was just curious
uh because our
our fields have some overlapping i was
wondering i can imagine there's a lot of
confounding factors in your field and
you're trying to
analyze your data and i was just
wondering if your company is able to
make use
of ap testing at all um or
you know but by any you know by whatever
you want to call it a b tester or
testing in general
and uh or i was wondering if just by you
know the virtue of
your clients if you're limited to lack
of a better term like retrospective
analysis and
as a follow-up question if you're not
doing that i was wondering if your
clients are actually interested in doing
things like that or if you feel like you
have pushback about things like this
because it
requires like a scale up initially you
know whereas retrospective testing they
people just dump the data on your desk
and say here you go figure it out but a
b testing requires data scientists to
kind of have a seat at the table up
front as well to organize the test so
just
wondering if you're making use of this
or if you just feel like there's
pushback about
stuff like this from your clients yeah
that's a really interesting question
so we're trying to do both both
do experiments that are designed
in a way to let us do better
cleaner analysis and analyze the data
that we have despite
confounding factors and so there's
a lot of different ways to approach
experimentation so sometimes we can
compare
sales to control stores and things
and that can be helpful but doesn't
really scale
in our case to our standard campaigns so
it's more of an exception
to do some pilot experiments
and once we've fully rolled out then
there's a really
interesting challenge there where people
do want to do experiments both within
the company
people are interested in doing
experiments and we have clients who are
interested
in testing things but
there's a lot of thought to put into how
to do them and some of the factors are
figuring out how to do experiments that
don't have a huge
additional burden of work so
for things that you know things like
films that are
a lot of work to create and aren't just
digitally generated
and where we have uh you know a limited
number
of places that we can test different
things than there's
thinking about like how do we do this
within the context of how the business
operates
in a way that makes use of things that
we're already doing or that adds
you know an amount of work that's
acceptable so that's one thing and
that's where
being at a small company it's much
easier to understand all the different
pieces of the company and how they work
together
and how you know this great experiment
that you're thinking of in isolation how
that plays out in reality for all the
other teams
who would have to be involved and also
just a lot easier to have those
conversations because we all
know and understand each other in terms
of our roles
the other interesting thing is that
you know if you're trying to measure the
impact on sales you almost
by definition have to sacrifice some
sales in order to do
an experiment so
to detect an effect will there have to
be something that we think will impact
sales and then the question is well do
we know how much
and how much is too much for something
that we're running where
you know we're trying to run something
that's effective and so we don't want to
intentionally
make part of the campaign less effective
just to measure it if we can avoid it so
we have uh right now an approach where
we are trying to generate hypotheses
from historical data
um knowing that there are some
confounding factors that can't entirely
be
separated out and then also think about
how we test
some of those hypotheses with
experimentation and being creative about
the ways
that we can do that and so we have
multiple possibilities
that that we're thinking about and we do
some
experiments currently but um but would
like to build that in
as a more regular piece of what we're
doing
cool thank you very much for the info i
appreciate it
can i add a question onto that how do
you
ensure that experiments are taken
all the way through right so a challenge
of mine is set up a bunch of experiments
and then some drop by the wayside um
yeah so so i guess if you have a series
of experiments that you
kind of need to work through to
get an answer than that then that follow
through can be a problem
we have fairly discreet time periods
that we work with and so we can plan an
experiment for a particular
time period and customer
set of stores and run that and and
analyze the results and um it has to be
set up
in advance in a way that kind of
requires buy-in from everyone so we
haven't had
that problem but i think just generally
um
getting people on board with with
experimentation as
a valuable and and feasible thing to do
is
probably uh an ongoing challenge
in a lot of places but i think when it
when it works out well and you can say
we think this is what's going on and now
we can do a much simpler
kind of head-to-head comparison then
it's easier for people to
understand the results and think through
it themselves and not have this complex
model in the background that's
um that's a bit mysterious so i think
uh when it works it can build a lot of
credibility with what you're learning
but yeah figuring out how to do
experiments without making everything
really complex and
and hard on people is definitely part of
the challenge
when you say fall by the wayside like
what do you
actually mean like why robert like why
do your
tests like can you elaborate on that
sure so full disclosure i'm not a data
scientist but we do uh
some degree of testing on our marketing
team
and when i say fall by the way side
right so i'm
i don't always have an experiment plan
like so i'll have
i'll have a way to measure two things
set an a b test live
set a few lives and then one sort of you
know catches my interest more than all
the others and to sort of stop paying
attention to the test right so
the failure i guess is not having a
clear objective and then not having a
clear time frame
and then uh i blame my teammates for not
holding me accountable
i would too i i definitely
so i think uh so we have a testing hold
testing experimentation team
uh where i work and um uh
i know they take like the roadmap very
seriously so any test gets scored in a
way
um that they try to understand the
effort of that
the impact and all of those things so
maybe some of that would help
if you had like all of your testing
ideas and you would kind of put them in
a
list of priorities of you know how much
business impact do they have
um you know is it gonna require a lot of
death time to set that up
what's the actual you know impact versus
the
um you know ease of rolling this out um
and then kind of just focusing on your
top ones uh that might just naturally
help you
uh you know prioritizing the ones that
you feel like are going to actually move
the needle
do you know how that team prioritizes
experiments like do they are they just
kind of taking
requests from stakeholders or do they
have a really clear mandate yeah
um so i i sit in like the marketing team
so i i lead a martin
analytics team um and that team also
sits inside of marketing so most of the
projects that we are getting are on the
acquisition marketing end
um but we do try try to like democratize
the in
the sort of incoming ideas so uh
if you if your function lives completely
outside of marketing
uh that doesn't mean that we wouldn't
like not take those tests
um and then there are several frameworks
that you can do to actually prioritize
tests
uh we internally use um like the there's
like this rice model
uh so like reach impact um effort
um to kind of like just try to kind of
get an idea of like
how uh you know what the business impact
would be for a project
um yeah and then and it essentially gets
built and
put in production
interesting it's interesting that
there's a whole team devoted to that
one one of the things kind of related to
testing that's higher level that i've
seen be effective and just kind of how
people think
is just trying to get people to
articulate their hypotheses
and that doesn't have to be necessarily
things that are easily
measurable with data in the traditional
sense but just like
what do we think is going on with our
industry and where
we play in it and and how our customers
operate and things like that and then
just writing those down and revisiting
them i think helps people
think about what are we learning and
when do we change
this kind of hypothetical knowledge that
we have
based on new information whether it's
data specifically or
you know the preponderance of the
experience of the sales team or whatever
it is
and that seems like a little bit more
lightweight way to get everybody on
board with
thinking that way and then obviously
there are some things where
data and structured experiments are
important to answering those questions
but even just the
structured thinking i think is helpful
in staying on top of things
let's may shift yours a little bit here
but there's a question from david
related more to training um and david
would you be able to introduce yourself
and
you know add some context to that
question as well yeah i'll be happy to
so my name is david dreyer
i'm a technical expert in product safety
and data science at
crop protection and uh you know the
question here is
within our company there's this global
effort to increase digital fluency
and several folks in our team and
product safety are looking to up skill
and data science specifically in r
i've been asked to coordinate a series
of training sessions so i'm curious
if others on those calls had had a
similar experience in their company
if they have any suggestions you know
things that have worked things that
haven't worked
um this just came across my desk
yesterday so i just thought i'd ask the
crowd and
learn more about others experiences here
to add to that i'd be interested in
anyone's experience with
supporting people and learning r or or
other programming languages
versus encouraging people to learn sql
first
rami do you have anything to add there
or would you be able to provide some
perspective
i think this is where we failed so i
probably should not give advice on this
like we have a
team on finance today using excel and
we got to the point that we all
recognize that they probably should
start use our more
but we did not find the time or the
method to really to do it so i'm
hi everybody um i just want to step in
my my experience was
okay i should introduce myself as well
i'm steve charlesworth i'm a
data scientist at cook medical we make
medical devices
um i've had a similar experience we have
a lot of people
researchers using excel and you know
i've kind of taken it
actually upon myself to to introduce
people to r and try to you know assist
them to the degree i can
to get up to speed and we've definitely
had success stories
where the you know the people are
motivated and pretty sharp to begin with
you know
you have some good luck there but i feel
like to really make that happen you
maybe
really need like some management
blessing and a little more structure and
formality around it maybe you know get
people sent to training
so that they get you know the message
you know not only that r is cool and
that you could do a lot of great
wonderful things with it but that you
know it's also something that you know
is expected as part of your
toolkit going ahead so that's just my
thoughts
i think it comes down to like showing
the value of something to
someone too right like um i think
like these top-down trainings just like
rarely work
right the way like okay everyone's gonna
learn python now everyone everyone's
gonna learn sql now whatever
um but like if you can show them that
you know hey you're doing this excel
based
process that's taking you like a day to
update up
update this excel sheet you can run this
run this function in an
r and actually understand what's going
on i think that's the only way to really
show or really get people to adopt it
because otherwise it's going to be
even after like you can do a month-long
training on our
and then like if you ask people six
months from now
you know i don't know how many of them
are actually going to transition into
that
into that process even though you've
given them the business training
um like really like the only way to get
people to actually adopt it
is to have them you know work with stuff
that they already do
so like have them actually do a project
that they're currently working on
and use r with it um and uh
you kind of like make them understand
themselves
that they uh by using this process can
actually help
help themselves a little bit better um
i'll agree with elaine though
i would go with sql first then r i think
that's a
you kind of like have to have that as a
foundation first uh
rather than uh you know jumping right in
that first
we did i would yeah just put in my vote
for sql before r2
as as they say sql is intergalactic data
speak so you got to know it
so i guess i'll wait here i've so i've
tried this at two different companies
um and i've had two different results uh
my previous company
i tried one i didn't try so much as i
was asked to host like
a couple of just training sessions just
show people hey here's how you do stuff
here's how
you assign variables and it was like a
room of like 10 or 12 people in there
and we did it maybe twice and i don't
know that anybody
got anything out of it right they were
all excel users
just you can't go like
and expect it to be quick and easy
and painless because it's not going to
be um
what i've actually started now here at
my current company
is uh basically like a brute force
scorched earth like they're going to
learn but
more of like so i have actually
scheduled with my team and i would take
advantage of the fact i have a small
three p team brothers just three people
under me
um we call it friday fun days we um
just pick a project and we the first few
i i coded i i would just read here's how
you read in data we're gonna go through
we're gonna work this project beginning
to end
and i did the first one and after
a few sessions that way i started going
around and
we all took we would all take turns it's
it's your day coding now it's your day
coding now it's your day coding
and um that's actually worked um
to some extent like people are more
comfortable and once you
you can't just leave it there though
because um
if if they aren't practicing on their
own as well those skills will still
you know atrophy um so i've said
you know what time so this team is more
definitely data centered
i don't know if you guys are familiar
with alteryx it's a codeless
you know kind of analytics platform so
they've had some experience
working with data like that but maybe
not necessarily in the code based
environment
so then i just said you know at times
guys i i don't expect you to pick it up
like
i know you can do some this first
project the first five projects i know
you can do quicker than all tricks
but i want you to do it in our to learn
um and that has helped but it is not
easy there's no anybody saying we're
just gonna
teach them and they're gonna learn and
it's gonna be great and it's just gonna
happen
needs to realize that's it's not how it
works
my experience has been that even pretty
motivated people
if they aren't actually using r for like
half the time in a given week
it's just that it can't get to the point
where they can get past
the initial problems and really
make progress and there was one time at
a previous company where we had a couple
people who were making a really
concerted effort to get more into the
bioinformatics side switching over from
being
dedicated lab biologists and they were
like
to somebody's point about managerial
support
they were like split time between the
two teams as a training exercise for
like a year
so they were actually immersed in
you know doing things with side side by
side with people who've been doing it
for years
and that seemed to work really
effectively but other than that i've had
a lot of people who've been really
interested in learning r
but they just haven't been able to work
it into their day-to-day jobs and they
can't find enough
extra time to really get there
sequel might be a little bit easier in
that regard
i'll say i'm definitely not an expert
on this but um i feel like this question
does come up quite a bit at a bunch of
different
industry meetups or the boston usar
group that i run
um and i think it kind of goes back to a
lot of
what people have touched upon as well
but really like
or tips that people share is really just
go and produce something
so find something that is taking them
a really long time to do as you
mentioned matias in excel
and how could they go about making that
more reproducible
and starting to like see the value in
using r right from the beginning
um like for me personally like that's
something that i've
been trying to do in my own role so even
whether
in sales or marketing for example like
after a webinar i would have this like
sheet of all the questions that people
ask and then trying to figure out how do
i just put this into an r markdown
document
that i could easily share with people
and it was
a little more painful in the beginning
of figuring out how to do it but now
that i have it set up i can just
do that after every session and it takes
like
one minute or so um
so maybe helping them like find those
areas where they could
make things easier for themselves
um so yeah and just one other thought
there and
i'll turn it over to someone else but
i think it'd also be helpful to maybe
try and find others
on your team that could help you and in
getting other people on board too
like there are probably other r users
at your company even if they're not
on the data science team but maybe even
in like
human resources or supply chain or
and they're reaching out to those people
and maybe like having a buddy with
helping you teach people might be really
helpful too
yes i i would like to add something
um so hi my name is cristal i work as
data analyst
um i am from costa rica so i want to
share a little bit of
my experience on this and i think as
christian mentioned uh at my work
there some of my team are working with
alteryx
so it's like a drag-and-drop tool
so it seems like more easy and
they think that it's more easy because
you're not coding because once you show
something
that has some code they just like
think that it's really difficult and
they do not have the time to spend
on learning um but what i find useful
is maybe if my team would like to use
that
then is to show the importance of using
our or
other tools that might be more useful
and what i
try to do is like with the stakeholders
or internal clients
every time that i they run a report and
then for example they build a report
that they have been working on two years
it is like their baby so they don't want
you to touch that baby that they have
built
in excel and you have to automate that
task
so what i find useful is to work side by
side with them
to explain what you are doing and to
show so they
for example yesterday i have this
experience in which
she just gets lost in all of the tabs
that she has in excel
so i mentioned her like see you think
like if we
can automate this in what i am doing
then you
you don't have to suffer to try to find
on all the tabs of excel
what you are build so to show the
benefits of using
r for example i think that's like to
make conscious on also these
stakeholders and
internal clients so then i can share
that
success stories to my team and then they
will find that
useful and then will they will try the
same
to other stakeholders that they have so
i really think that
it's not so easy like to make that
transition
in excel or alteryx and using our python
but i think that a clue of doing this
is to show the success stories and also
i think
it should be the commitment of the
managers
and they ha they need to have this
vision of
this is important so we can transfer
this knowledge to all of the team
so if anyone else has any thank you
very much crystal as well if anyone else
has anything to add
to that feel free to add more into the
chat too
but one question that i'd like to
start at ulaan is how do you
communicate the value of data science to
executives or for people that are just
trying to
build out a data science team within
their company
yeah i think if you are
the first data scientist or or working
on building that early team
there's some
questions to ask which hopefully you
have insight into although not always
about
why you were hired in the first place
and so especially if it's a small
company somebody is making a big
investment
in hiring a data scientist and it's good
to understand
what the thinking was behind that which
is not always
entirely logical well-informed thinking
it can be just like well we have data
and
data is really valuable and so we need a
data scientist
and that is challenging coming in but
then does you know give you the
opportunity to kind of
clarify where data science can be
helpful and educate people and it's good
to know that that's what you're
stepping into and then i think there are
other cases where there's a particular
need
that data scientists or analysts are
being hired for
um and that's good to know also so i
think regardless of
it's it's good to understand that like
why are you here or why do people think
you're here and then how do you work
with that beginning context
um and then also look at the business
and where there's value to be provided
in data um
and helping executives kind of
understand
where it makes the most sense for you to
focus which may or may not be
what they imagined initially um
but i think so so i think it depends
somewhat on
on the business and the leadership and
the kind of the the nature of the
organizational buy-in that you have and
you have to think about that context
but more broadly i think if there's
something that carries over
to most places in terms of data science
though it's about making sure
that you're making well-informed
investments and so if you're investing
in product development teams or you're
investing
in acquiring certain data or
in you know optimizing things with your
customers
pretty much anything it's valuable to
know
how much impact is that having and what
things did we invest in
that we're not really getting a good
return on
um and how do we you know reconfigure
our focus to the things that are um
that are providing the most return and
so i think
that's the kind of framing that fits
best with the way that executives are
thinking about the business
and where data has a legitimate role to
play
and then how to translate that into
what you work on and how quickly you can
provide results that
let them make those kinds of decisions
because sometimes you're walking into a
situation where there's been no
you know real data infrastructure or
collection efforts and so
it's it's hard to get things up and
running but
i think like that that kind of framing
that fits with
business leadership
is the best way to to start in terms of
connecting to executives
how much do you push back
and then how do you get comfortable with
pushing back or positioning yourself as
an expert to the
rest of the business that like you you
know best on what what should be
prioritized in
in david in uh data science projects
yeah i don't think i would say it that
way
because it's not always true for one
right i think it's a
it's a collaboration of
hearing from people in the business of
what's what's most useful for them
and going back and forth between where
we the data experts both can provide
value based on
you know the data that's available and
where we think there's the most
value to be found based on you know what
we think is possible
with the data and aligning that with
the problems people have and i think the
more you can get to
the kind of underlying problems they're
trying to solve
and get past just the straight up
you know tell me
send me this data set or tell me how
this compares to this the better
off you are and so the kind of product
management approach of asking why
and getting down to like a user story
type level where someone's saying on
i need to do this because i'm trying to
accomplish this
allows you some leeway to say okay well
now you know i
understand your problems and now let me
help
figure out how data can best address
those
but it's easy for us to see data
problems and data solutions to things
and that
may not align with the most critical
priorities of the business so there's
like an
ongoing effort that you have to make to
understand what's going on
with the people you're trying to provide
value to
and especially rapidly evolving
companies that's
constantly changing so it's a
non-trivial task to keep up
mike i see you have your hand raised
there
sorry if i missed it from before no no
no that's okay i just had a lot of
thoughts
on this topic of communicating to
leadership what data science
can't canon can't do um i think
you know especially once you get to the
point of having a data science
organization i think a lot of data
science scientists will tell you that
instead of you know modelers or
analytics people that we're
problem solvers at kind of our core and
i think that that's
that's really the way that we need to
sell data science
to the c-suite is that we're
a function for solving problems i
remember i used to see this
this stupid analytics pyramid
that was like we're going to start out
with descriptive analytics and then
we're going to go to predictive
analytics and then we're going to do
machine learning and then we're going to
do ai at the top once we get to like
our most mature point in our
organization and i just
don't think that that communicates what
data science is
very well to non-technical folks at all
um i don't think i think
a particular problem is suited for a
particular solution
and i think that half of the time the
c-suite is just looking for something to
be automated
which isn't a data problem at all and i
think you need to have somebody who
understands
um i think going back to what elaine
says you know that translational
component
of come to me with your problem that
your business problem
and i'm going to tell you if it's a data
problem or if it's not a data problem at
all
and how data science you know can or
can't be used to solve it
is report the best output in terms of
the solution that we're going to deliver
to you or do we need to
build you a model and put that in an api
that
fits into our current business process
um so that somebody's not you know
running a model on their own laptop so i
think
it really comes down to problem solving
at a high level
and i think that a lot of the sales and
marketing material that's
that's been out there for a while
doesn't do us justice
as the data scientists who are on the
ground trying to communicate and trying
to help
the business move forward and solve its
problems
thank you mike and um if you wouldn't
mind introducing yourself i think
it'd be helpful to maybe share your your
company too
oh sure you don't want me to just rant
the whole time
no i love that i appreciate it yeah
my name is michael thomas i'm the chief
data scientist at catch brook analytics
which we're a data science consulting
firm out of the hartford connecticut
area
really focusing on that whole end-to-end
data science
life cycle in terms of getting the
problem the business problem
translating it into a data problem and
then um
actually deploying the solution kind of
from end to end
and we highly specialize in our i'm a
certified our studio
and shiny instructors so live breathe
r when i can
thanks mike it's it does seem like a lot
of
the topics end up going back to
communication
and elaine i was just curious like what
are
specific things that you think data
scientists can do
today or like things that you've maybe
taught to people on your team
to really get better at communicating
data science
one of the things i know i've told
people on my team
repeatedly over time and also try and
tell myself
is to go through the process
of trying to look at what you're doing
from your audiences
or stakeholders perspective three times
which may not even be enough
and try and like strip away the data
scientist
specific piece of it and get it closer
and closer to
you know someone who's arriving at this
meeting and is going to pay attention
for maybe 15 minutes and has
problems they want to solve what do they
want to hear about how can they consume
that and what do they not
want to hear about um
and so that process of like do that
three times like present to other people
on your team present to other people in
the company and get feedback
it's uh it's really hard to get in just
one step of i did this and now i'm going
to try and present it
to that the right level of
communication simplicity and and
audience awareness so that's
one thing um and then i think just
getting exposure
exposure to other teams and other parts
of the business wherever possible
really helps build
empathy and understanding for other
people's
perspectives so whether that's like
getting out into the field
or sitting in on other teams
discussions just generally trying to
understand where everyone else is
coming from and what kinds of
pressures and challenges they're dealing
with is really helpful
not just for not just for formulating
what problems we solve and
having kind of contextual awareness of
building models and things but in
communicating with people also
it feels like an hour just went by
really quickly
so we're gonna we'll stay on if if
people don't have to run to other
meetings
um but just wanted to make sure i didn't
miss any questions
rob and rob for monitoring the chat
but one other question i think has i'm
trying to ask
everybody each week is what advice would
you have
for someone who's looking to get into a
data science leadership
position and i think this is something
we did touch upon in
in the webinars italy
yeah i think um expanding
your the time you spend and the emphasis
you put
on things other than the data work
to understanding the business better
understanding what executives care about
and what their perspective is
getting lots of practice everywhere you
can
communicating to different groups and
then also
like how you kind of think about not
just prioritizing things within your
team
but communicating those priorities
effectively
and so depending on your position you
may just be kind of observing other
people do these things
but um there's often opportunities
to jump in and maybe even take over
tasks that your
current leader doesn't want to do like
you know
updating road maps and
and communicating where things stand and
stuff that's good practice and
and just kind of getting a lot of
feedback on how people
interpret things and what people care
about and and how to
how to do that kind of thing but there's
also um
almost always opportunities to just you
know go find people who work in other
parts of the company and
sit down and hear what they're working
on and and
get that broader perspective that's not
data specific
because a lot of the leadership stuff is
not so much about data as it is about
how you interact with everyone else
i see the comment about money is what
matters when it comes to executives
i really do think understanding
executives is a fascinating
undertaking um
like just thinking about preparing
graphs that executives are going to
present or consume
i once told someone on my team long ago
like
he actually wrote a function called
execufy and like basically this needs to
take the graphs we have
and make it look like they were drawn
with a crayon
like simple big you know
and and that's the kind of thing that
often gets in the executive level
communications and then the question is
why because sometimes it seems like it
gets dumbed down the higher
it goes but executives are
generally very sharp people many of whom
have come from very detailed technical
backgrounds right so it's not about the
people it's about the
responsibilities they have and the
perspective they have and i think
really trying to understand that is
really helpful
in thinking about how to support them in
running the business and they do care
about money which can be frustrating but
is also really important if you want to
stay
employed and work for a company that has
money to spend on
data scientists and stays in business so
it's uh somebody has to care about that
and we have to support them in some way
and doing their jobs
so i know we are getting to the end of
the time here so
anyone has to to drop no worries but i'd
love to keep this conversation
going if people are able to
um and it sounds like i know in the
middle of the talk today we were talking
a bit about how to get other people on
board internally
or people that are using excel and maybe
wanting to switch to r
and it it felt like that was something
we should maybe
chat about more are there other topics
or other things that people would like
to
discuss
i'd love to know what you look for when
hiring elaine
so because i'm usually hiring onto small
teams at small
companies and teams that i don't expect
to grow to be
20 people in the next year or two i
tend to look for people who are
generalist
to a certain degree and so i think about
like the the whole spectrum from like
data engineering all the way to
uh maybe data visualization or whatever
is the kind of last stage of
communicating things
and all the pieces in between which is
you know analytics engineering and
and modeling and analysis and all of
that
and and look for people who have a
strength in some area that we don't yet
have
but can flex to cover almost everything
else with
some level of competence
um because it's so hard to predict
exactly what we need and it tends to
fluctuate over time because we're kind
of covering whatever
the company needs that fits in our area
and then the other thing is
communication as you can probably guess
from everything i said
to this point so we actually have an
exercise people do where they do a
little analysis and then prepare a slide
and that's pretty key
i don't know if you could think off the
top of your head but what are some
things that
folks get wrong when they are
communicating insights either in your
hiring test or
actually on the job
um i think the most common is to talk
way too much about the things that are
really important for how you did the
work
and not enough about the result
so like this is the type of model we
used these are the assumptions
you need to cover some of that at least
be able to answer questions but
mostly nobody cares
just don't i mean people within your
team should care and
you should care but that's our
responsibility to care about
nobody else really wants to know most of
the time
um on the topic of hiring elaine i know
last week i think it was we were talking
a bit about
when um like how to stand out to
to hiring managers when there's so much
like nlp
behind resumes and like what can people
do to get around that
yeah i may not be the best person to
answer that because
um smaller companies tend to be a little
bit more hands-on
but maybe that explains some of the
resumes that i see that have lists of 10
000 technologies
if they're trying to work with
algorithms um
i often find that people stand out
pretty easily
so it's quite likely nobody will read
your cover letter
but you should still write one well
um and just having your resume be
you know formatted typo free targeted
stands out a lot instead of the list of
like i can do all these
things although that may be effective in
other contexts but it's not in the
context i hire
i remember kobe mentioned that on the
webinar like you'd get resumes with just
like a
bunch of different technologies listed
yeah i mean it's like an seo
strategy almost maybe like i i need to
communicate this thing but then i also
need to tag it with 10 000 things that
some algorithm might be looking for
yeah i see steve said one resume for
people
one for machines i guess
i don't see any other questions i'm
trying to scroll through and
double check but just want to say thank
you so much elaine
for all the insights and opening up to
the group
i also just want to ask if people have
other questions for you what's the best
way to get in touch with you
um probably twitter
for people who use twitter i keep up
with that much better than linkedin
and so it's ea mcveigh on twitter
perfect well thank you so much have a
great rest of the day everyone
bye everybody bye
you